turning now to the wildfires this
morning nearly 100 major wildfires are
burning out of control in a dozen
western states in san francisco smoke
from the fires made the sky turn red in
the middle of the day
no filter and that is daytime the
disaster has destroyed hundreds
or maybe thousands of homes in the
region and killed at least seven people
they include a woman and her young
grandson in oregon where the damage
has been immense lilia luciano is there
violent wind-driven flames cut a path of
destruction across
parts of southern oregon this could be
the greatest loss
of human lives and property due to
wildfire in our state's history
the wildfires nearly wiped out five
towns
including the city of phoenix this is
what one of its senior living centers
looked like before
and this is after 89 year old beth hill
was evacuated
just in time the center has burned with
all of our things
everything i own is there not only me
but everybody else
twelve-year-old wyatt tofti and his
grandmother peggy mosso
died trying to escape the fire a family
member telling cbs news
the family's cart wouldn't start police
tell us
that up until moments before this entire
rv park
was overpowered by the flames its
residents kept trying to put them out
with buckets and hoses but their valiant
efforts were just not enough
we spotted this man carrying out what he
could salvage from his home
including his father's headstone that's
one of the only items you have left
that my son my wife and a few tools
for days firefighters have been battling
a relentless siege of wildfires from
washington
to california where just north of
sacramento the so-called bear fire
destroyed the community of berry creek
and killed at least three people a dozen
others are missing
brenda hampton evacuated but hadn't
heard from her sons
she lost her home in paradise to the
campfire
just two years ago now this new fire is
threatening that town once again
i just want to know where the rest of my
family is
two days after the fire this area is
still smoldering
it's home to many latino families in
this community yesterday i talked to
some of them
who were saying they were coming back to
find answers as to where to go
next many with their children just to
give you an idea of how massive these
fires are
the smoke from california is reaching
all the way to the islands of hawaii
gail oh it's heartbreaking to see the
pictures thank you very much lillian
we're thinking about the people there